today I'm cooking hearty food recipes
with the generous helping of warmth
comfort and Indulgence
it's honest food with big and satisfying
flavors that really grab your taste buds
and makes no apologies so when you want
to welcome your friends or family back
home after a nice long walk or an
exhausting football match these are the
recipes to do it with this is my
ultimate hearty food
first up a hearty breakfast of smoked
haddock with spinach baked eggs
that that's beautiful for lunch the
ultimate comfort of a hearty creamy
tomato soup
that's delicious
served with Rich and delicious Welsh
rare bit
look at those babies that just takes
cheese and toast to another level
and my youngest daughter Tilly joins me
making beef and Ale stew with mustard
dumplings
and that's the only way I want you to
taste beer
followed by a scrumptious pear and
Ginger galette
three delicious full-bodied comforting
meals breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with a hearty breakfast of
smoked haddock and spinach baked eggs
this boat haddock one of my favorite
fish delicious
highly sustainable it's packed with
protein lightly smoked there's not a Dye
smoke there's a big difference see I've
got that bright yellow tinge
so much better
next baby spinach there's a spinach
that's very young full of zinc great
flavor a little teaspoon volleyball knob
of butter
that little touch of oil stops the
butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach
but it's going to disintegrate almost by
two-thirds when I'm cooking spinach and
butter open up the top of my pepper
Mills so the pepper becomes almost like
so Cracked Pepper not so fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two-thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
tag them it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart
pick off the little buds from the stalks
keep all of these and grateful when
you're making a tag of vinegar red wine
vinegar tag and stalks in
chop the target into your creme fraiche
little season
now grain mustard goes brilliantly well
with haddock
incredible this mustardy Herby creme
fresh will work equally well partnered
with grilled chicken the haddock's
starting to flake because it's smoked
lightly cured it Cooks so quickly you
creme fresh
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are going
to bake on top so you've got this
wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off
now
crack your eggs around the outside
just a little twist of pepper get the
remainder of your creme fresh and put a
little dollop in between that adds
richness to the egg whites into the oven
at 180
for 10 to 12 minutes
what's the haddock and eggs baked
together I can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
in professional kitchen chefs refuse to
use the top of the spring onions but I
love that nice dark green flavor it says
harsh than the white the smell of baked
mustard you can't beat
that is beautiful
spinach has almost melted in with a had
it now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
My ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron you'll be raring
to dive into the day ahead
for my ultimate hearty lunch and dinner
you need some hearty ingredients
here's a more in-depth look at some of
the key ones you'll need to buy
made from roasted malt hops water and
yeast Stout Porter was the preferred
Bevy of London's River Porters in the
18th century
but this bridge bitter tasting beer is
linked with food goes way back too
not only is it the perfect hearty Tipple
to wash down a couple of oysters it
works its magic in soups stews pies and
cakes too
thank you
so it's a classic English ingredient
since the Middle Ages
half waxy fat is taken from around the
kidneys and loins of beef or mutton
today so it is still prized for
imparting a unique lightness and Rich
but subtle flavor to Savory and sweet
steamed puddings
and today I'll be rolling up traditional
mustard suet dumplings to hearty up a
slow-cooked beef stew
Ginger a zingy and versatile medicinal
and culinary heavyweight
used powdered it adds punch to cakes
biscuits and beer crystallized is eaten
as lip smacking sweet meat
and the fresh or pickled fibers root
adds vibrant heat to dishes the length
and breadth of Asia I'll be using a
triple Ginger measure to give depth and
spice to wonderful classic pear and
ginger Gillette
when it comes to my ultimate hearty
lunch it's got to be soup soups can be
light and delicate or Rich and gutsy
they're versatile practical and easy to
make and for my ultimate hearty lunch
I'm making one of my childhood favorites
roasted tomato soup
beautiful Vine Tomatoes The Ripe in the
tomatoes the better the soup take the
core out get your thumb and place it
half a centimeter underneath the tip of
your knife place it in and then just
twist around that's the only part of the
Tomato that we're not using red onion
and garlic Red Onion because it's
sweeter than a white onion
slice your onions and your garlic
nice and fine traditionally we make it
in a pot it's so much better to start it
off on top of the stove searing the
tomatoes and the garlic but it goes in
the oven you actually roast the tomatoes
and they don't stew there's a big
difference in flavor be quite generous
with the olive oil it makes the soup
nice and glossy shiny salt pepper and
then a little teaspoon of cayenne just
gives it that heat but it's not as
Fierce as chili
take your Tomatoes just slice them in
half
and then
a little touch of sugar that's gonna
help intensify the sweetness
a little sprinkle of aged off with
vinegar gives that nice dark Rich
acidity to the soup
into the oven 20 25 minutes 180.
to make my soup even more irresistible
I'm going to make a Punchy sun-dried
tomato pesto to drizzle over the top
now I'm making this in a pestle and
mortar because you feel so much more in
control and you're not depending on a
blade that's whizzing around a thousand
miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts
toast them the absolute Max and then in
smelling those incredible
parmesan
slightly grate that
this is where it starts to become creamy
extra virgin olive oil
doesn't need salt because the parmesan
is going to season it for you
and just take a couple of tablespoons of
the oil the sun-dried tomatoes are in
really helps to make that stunning pesto
I can smell those roasted tomatoes I
want them out
wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes
put your spoon through those Tomatoes
they break up instantly bring that up to
the boil let it simmer for three or four
minutes
I want to make a little bit more
creaming out creaming
give that a little stir you can keep it
rustic and get your Masher in and you've
got that nice thick Rich Chunky Tomato
Soup
or give yourself a stick blender
blitzing it like that you deglaze the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom
um
that's delicious
to make my lunch extra hearty I'm going
to knock up a deliciously gutsy version
of cheese on toast to go with my tomato
soup watch Rabbit an absolute classic
I'm gonna make a roux 50 pounds of
butter three nice tablespoons of flour
and that's all the roux is basically
traditionally you would use flour butter
and milk
but in Welsh rabbit the milk is often
cheekily substituted for a stiff slug of
stout it gives it that strong gutsy
flavor
I want it nice and thick make sure those
lumps are out
a nice teaspoon of Dijon mustard and
then season it
nice and spicy with Worcestershire sauce
gives it that delicious intriguing
Flavor now that smells amazing
almost brings tears to your eyes
beautiful
now whilst rabbit wouldn't be a stunning
Welsh rabbit without Rich mature cheese
so I'm a great
Montgomery cheddar goes well with the
beer
and drop that in really important to put
this in by the roux still nice and hot
because the cheese melts
now for the bread
I prefer a good rustic country loaf that
will stand up to my hardcore topping
I want that nice crisp base to my Welsh
rabbit so toast it both sides
spread that beautiful cheesy Berry spicy
mixture just great
got a blister
and bubble and gratinate
God
a little splash alien Perry
and back under the grill for 90 seconds
in one delicious
creamy roasted tomato soup it's coming
back to me all those days I had off
school I used to purposely lie about
feeling ill just to get a bowl of my
mother's tomato soup
how bad was that but my God it was worth
it oh
now my Welsh rabbit
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast to another level
wow roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto served with the
most amazing delicious Welsh rabbit
I feel like bringing in sick
some of the best hearty dinners I can
think of are slow cooked recipes made
with robust deep flavored ingredients
and left to Bubble away for hours until
they become glossly rich this is the
sort of food that really gives you
plenty of energy and protects you
against cold winter weather so for my
ultimate Hearty dinner I'm doing a dish
that every home cook should have a
recipe for a great stick to your ribs
stew here's my favorite beef and Ale
with mustard dumplings
foreign
first things first I'd like you to
season the students day
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flower going to do
dad the flower helps to Brown the beef
seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew I feel a bit
like marshmallows you do feel a little
bit marshmallow don't they look at the
size of the chunks of the beef
I'm gonna cut my carrots literally
similar similar sizes right does that
mean they'll cook equally that's right
now these are little pearl onions I'm
going to put them in whole as well
everything has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burn garlic before
Oh Matilda
probably mention that
what is that
time time and what they
Bailey's Bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in the beef goes in first okay in
now really nice color it's a beautiful
color
remember the carrots thymine good job
garlic pearl onions in good
give that a really good mix up
shoes are very easy to make providing at
the beginning you give it a little bit
of love
now that's all juicy browned
that bear that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan adding beer or Stout
helps to tenderize the beef and give it
a hearty delicious flavor
and that's the only way I want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
I'm going to add in a couple of
teaspoons of tomato puree please
in fact three please because it's so
nice and there's one final thing in
there cover this tuna steak with a big
stock give that a little mix with Daddy
please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you start um serve it
oh yes is the Garlic going to be burnt
no excuse me
right the wheels put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
be trying to not make the stew or watery
into the oven at 150 please tell us for
about two and a half hours and now
getting focused on your homework
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato Classics in one twice baked
bubble and sweet jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
we shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute and butter and add a dash of
water until tender
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and
cooked through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato Center
then Mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato Classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
right homework done yeah
mysterious chewing stewing let's get on
with our delicious hearty pet tart I've
been looking forward to this you and I
Chef I'm gonna prep the pears so if you
peel I'll top and tell into quarters
pears go soft in the oven very very
quickly so we're going to put them on a
tart we'll need to leave them whole half
or in quarter what's that in there
Ginger that's right a stem Ginger so
when you use stem Ginger and fresh
ginger next add your stem Ginger a
little of the stem ginger syrup good
girl and some brown sugar to your
quartered pears
and then just grate some fresh ginger
off you go so it's a bit of a different
one to grate this because it doesn't
really come through like the cheese no
I'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there right what we need to do
now is give that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff we can make it so easy to do
so give me your finger that's my center
point I want you to get the pears going
around like that in a really nice Circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pairs keep on sliding all over the place
yeah
so egg wash the outside and I'm going to
show you a little trick so you lift that
up so see egg wash acting like a bit of
a glue that's right crimple this but
pastry form this nice little shelf like
a little money bag are you going to do
anything with the spare pairs oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
we've got the fresh ginger and those
nice little bits of stem Ginger let me
go around Mike with your glue we might
glow just on top
Tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully
it's a bit like snow isn't it now that
glazes the pastry so the pastry has this
really nice shine on there as well
finally the lemon on top
put that there
180 and in she goes
can you smell the beef
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it
okay I want you to just I was hoping
you'd asked
taste
how's that taste now
you're not allowed anymore
all right dumpling time flowering please
I'm using self-raising flour for a
fluffy result but if you like your
dumplings hard use plain flour next The
Dumpling essential suet that makes the
dumplings nice and moist
by a generous dollop of grain mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round Another
Touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
fingers are getting tired right now put
your hand in there now you should bring
all that dough together
actually the best way to get that nice
and clean sprinkles and flour on your
hands rub them together
all that will come off
it's a good way is it now we've got this
wonderful dumpling mixture how squid is
that oh
a little flower on your hands okay roll
these blend ways
and then I want you to follow my lap in
your hand
I'll figure
smell that mustard in there
huh
come on
ever trust you or something like that
yes please silly
gently let's go in at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
and put that back into the oven
for 20 minutes to cook the dumplings now
if you open the door for daddy I'm going
to take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our petard has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby
foreign would you like me to start
testing yes please
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look delish okay I'll
check on the dumplings
now look they've sort of doubled in size
well definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
I might have to have a quick taste
before we go just to check I mean we
have to be sure
that is an amazing hearty beef stew
dumpling smoke the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate Hearty dinner a
comforting Rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and Ginger galette
ready for some delicious beef stew yeah
oh wow thank you very much delicious
thank you will we be able to heat this
up for mum and Jack when they come back
easy even two or three days later toasty
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
packed full of sumptuous homely dishes
today's all about comfort food I think
every home cook needs recipes that don't
just taste delicious but have satisfy
the soul too the type of food that wraps
his arms around you and gives you big
hugs so when you want to give your
family and friends a big serving of Love
here's my ultimate comfort food dish is
guaranteed to make you feel cozy even on
the coldest of days
first up a breakfast that will bring you
a warm glow in the morning my spiced
baked porridge perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast for lunch I'm pulling
out all the stops with a fantastic Twist
on one of Britain's favorite comfort
dishes ginger beer battered fish with
chili minted mushy peas It's Gonna Do It
do it properly for dinner my youngest
daughter Tilly is in the kitchen and we
share the secret ingredient in every
comfort food dish happy memories
when she made them for you always such
as hot pot with beetroot and potato
gratins on the menu for dessert spiced
apple compos silly we're on for a treat
this is my ultimate comfort food
breakfast lunch and dinner
first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
I grew up with it there's something very
Scottish about porridge it's that kind
of sort of great start to the day my
father used to say porridge needs salt
and salt only it separates the men from
the boys didn't really like it it was
insisted salt puts hairs on it and I
used to sneak a couple of sugar lumps
from cafes and put them in my porridge
without him watching these days my
porridge has much more flavor than just
salt it's packed with fruit nuts and
spices add vanilla seeds to porridge
oats or oatmeal really important just to
rub the vanilla through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
already
that
smells incredible I quite like making
this up week at a time and Jack
absolutely loves it now whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but I quite like the sort of
texture hazelnuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pot in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
I'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango I love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
it can be done the night before left in
the fridge and then a couple of minutes
before you go to bake it add your cream
into your dish
it looks quite liquid but by the time it
bakes has this really nice rich crust on
top and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top
now bake at 180 for 30 to 35 minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
Demerara sugar and Grill to create a
sweet Golden Crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful literally for three to four
minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be Scottish
because it's perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast it's Rich it's
Sumptuous and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spiced baked porridge with all those
nuts and fruit it's a bowl full of love
to start the day
next I'm showing you how to cook the
comfort food I crave
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
make them
My ultimate comfort food has to be
sausage I grew up on the classic British
Banger made with ground pork salt pepper
spices and breadcrumbs and I'm using
these ones for dinner
the general rule with sausage the higher
the meat content the better they'll
taste
for my ultimate lunch I'm frying fish so
you'll need an oil you can get to a high
temperature here are the different oils
you can use
groundnut oil it's made from peanuts and
it's used a lot in Southeast Asian
cooking
grape seeds made from those yellow
flowering crops this has the lowest
saturated fat content of any oil and has
a lovely delicate flavor
foreign
oil made from sunflower seeds is mildly
nutty
cheap all-rounder with a neutral flavor
is vegetable oil which is the blend of
oils like corn soybean and sunflower
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from China but today in
Britain we grow over 2 000 different
types
the most popular eating apples in the UK
are Braven and Gala but don't miss out
on some of the older types like the
sweet nutty russets and fragrant coxes
when it comes to cooking apples it's got
to be a sharp Bramley which I'm using as
part of my compot for lunch
you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food multimet
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas I've loved it ever since I was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
I've given it a few modern tweaks
for my Ultimate Fish I'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of Ginger to go with it
chili minted mushy peas
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm
the secret is to season the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that'll keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic that the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour I want a bit of heat in the batter
so a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then two teaspoons of baking powder
this almost lightens the lobe of the
batter now ginger beer it gives that
batter the sort of unique spicy
individual flavor is delicious for the
fish and a nice tablespoon of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
Sheen give that a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of double cream
too thin and the batter runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture let it rest for as long as
possible to give you an even textured
batter now the season should have worked
its magic and drawn out the excess
moisture from the fish so it's on to the
next stage fish
I was going slightly firm
perfect for frying start by coating the
fish in flour seasoned with pepper hats
that nice and dry into your hands so you
haven't got any excess flour the flour
stops the batter from running off the
fish I'm just gonna check to see if my
oil's ready by putting a little touch of
batter into the fryer you see it
bubbling straight to the very top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever
fill the pan above halfway if the oil
starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist the pan
that stops IT from sticking at the
bottom oil should be gently sort of
bubbling away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no spitting of any water from
the fish fry the fish for three to five
minutes gently turning halfway through
once the batter's golden and crisp it's
ready look they look stunning it's like
these big crispy pillows of beautifully
textured Cod leave the fish to rest on
the kitchen towel to blot excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chili
minted mushy peas
now how much your peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
a nice
knob of butter into the pan
shop finely chopped that adds a bit of
sweetness to the peas shots into the pan
chili
these are delicious when you eat peas
and they're slightly spicy they're even
better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chili the
garlic and the slots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water infused
with their perfect partner fresh mint
stalks on all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the piece I've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
I love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
Crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed delicious peas
those peas it's incredible
chopped mint
chili minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish
a nice spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms the importance of comfort food
if you're going to do it
do it properly
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic and the best way to
eat this is with Crispy buttered saute
potatoes cooked with garlic Rosemary and
Thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells from the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
I love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and I hope it will always remind my kids
of me
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood as my
youngest daughter Tilly
our food dinner is a stunning sausage
Hot Pot which will serve with a gorgeous
potato and beetroot gratin
now I love Hot Pot you love Hot Pot
and you love sausages right yeah what'd
you enjoy most about sausages
I just love having them
these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
we keep the hole and cut them into
quarters please now the important thing
about cooking sausages is they need a
bit of color right no color no flavor
exactly get the pan nice and hot how was
school today
school was good thanks we got to go out
and mix
sausages in
okay buttered mushrooms in there please
my darling see
now
I'm going to watch your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely
now sausages
I get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of Daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah yeah once
you've got the color on them
and check them out
to rest okay
a little knob of butter okay into the
pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that'll go down by half give that a
little fry okay salt in
I want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
pack the flavor
smells nice washrooms in give them a
nice little stir did you like to help
Nan make your hot pot when she made them
for you I used to always help now make
the hot pot
always now my mum would never have used
this but A's balsamic vinegar brings out
the flavor of the onions right now look
at her onions look beautiful caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss I'm gonna put my sausages back in
here now from there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven 170 in
the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes and she goes nice
to go with my hot pot Rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and I'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
then peel and thinly sliced potatoes and
cook beetroot
foreign
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
end with a neat layer of potatoes and
pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the Apple compod what we need to
do first is to get these peeled and
sliced
I got my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
come on
thanks for the warning
blew my head off they're incredibly
acidic okay and you need to cook them
those wonderful red apples you've got
are called Bray Burns what other apples
you know cream ones what are they called
um
the green ones another word for your nan
Grandma's no
red no Pink Lady apple no Granny Smith
Granny Smith apple that's right what
we're gonna do is cook the cooking
apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tartness from the
Bramley cooking apple with the sweetness
of the Brae bun get the pan nice and hot
sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're going to look for them okay
because once we use them and they've
worked their magic I need to pull them
out see all the sugar dissolving
now we just let that go a little bit
darker
okay and then
quick doesn't it
give that a nice
little toss
okay a nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
let me go into there what's that coming
out Dan so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show you we'll do that in a
minute how many Ginger
four four Ginger
and three cinnamon three cinnamon out
with a cinnamon
the ginger the gingers I'm gonna take
a spoon
of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the color of apples
these in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the Comfort sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to Crown the top
to separate the egg whites into there
for Daddy
but egg whites are in I think it's
separate off your good eye
and I'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
turn up the speed
here we go
there's your face now let's see if
you've got a really nice stiff Pig so
you lift them up
and that is what I call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad next in a
separate Bowl whip double cream until
stiff
nice and slowly
foreign
whips so much quicker
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compote puree
and you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple butterscotch now
to make the cream even lighter fold in
those whisked egg whites and sugar egg
whites
into the cream
just nicely fold that in
so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep good girl
hmm silly we're on for a treat open up
the Piping Bag
now to the end now you could spoon this
in I don't want to just give a nice
little lift it also gives it a nice
pattern lemon on top
the fridge the beetroot and potato
gratin is that lovely that's lovely
sausages oh finished with the flat leaf
parsley
look at those two beauties it doesn't
get any more comforting than that does
it for one of the best hot pots ever
Tilly that looks amazing
well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by Apple comp art
food with guaranteed feel-good Factor
mommy Jack Holly Megan
isn't it
smells amazing
foreign
delicious one of my favorites so tasty I
love it it's so good I love the
mushrooms as well that is so nice and so
simple when I was your age guys Nanny
was making this for me in those days the
sausages weren't as fast you would ride
to school on dinosaurs
excuse me I'm not out
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
foreign